bonjour merci d'avoir d'avoir accepté
notre invitation alors racontez nous un
peu ce que vous retenez vous de ce
discours en tout cas pour l'instant à
des manuels m'apprend déjà le président
va dans le bon sens cirque on est passé
d'un séparatisme au pluriel à au
séparatisme islamique dont il nomme il
nomme la chose après il ya plusieurs
angles morts dans ce qu'il a évoqué je
suis un peu gêné par déjà le titre de
son de son intervention la république en
actes est-ce que ça sous-entend que la
république n'était pas à l'action avant
ce discours là j'aurais préféré
personnellement peut-être une annonce du
type vaincre le totalitarisme islamique
qui aurait peut-être été plus juste
ensuite pour moi il ya un angle mort
assez importants sur sur sur ces
différentes annonces notamment celle de
la crise d'autorité de l'état
le cinquième point où il a beaucoup
insisté où le président vous comptez 6
tc notamment par l'école l'islam des
lumières réussir par l'éducation à ne
pas faire tomber les jeunes dans la
radicalité mais ceci va être possible
uniquement si on arrive à rétablir
l'autorité de l'état
un projet républicain et ça passe
notamment par des peines planchers et
beaucoup d'action qui est pouvoir
permettre à la réplique de regagner
l'influencent sur les territoires perdus
de la république notamment évoqué le
lien entre le trafic de stupéfiants et
la radicalité dans certains quartiers la
question la question le coeur du
problème et qu'ainsi elle c'est réussi à
reprendre le contrôle de ces de ces
territoires pour faire appliquer les
lois de la république
et puis enfin c'est aussi un problème
dans les services publics
il ya un excellent rapport d' eric diard
sur la radicalisation et les services
publics
on a eu des annonces sur un impératif de
neutralité pour les argents qu'ils aient
travaillé pour des missions de service
public qui sont pas directement des
fonctionnaires ça va dans le bon sens
dont on aurait pu aller plus loin
notamment dans les questions d'élise
communautaire imposé à interdire
l'appartenance à des associations
communautaires la présence sur certaines
niches
donc il ya des actions qui pourront être
mené et après il ya une interrogation
sert comment comment réellement va
pouvoir contrôler ces annonces le
président a évoqué la signature d'une
charte entre les associations et les
mairies pour notamment avoir des
subventions
comment ceci va être contrôlé ce qu'il y
aura vraiment un suivi précis de ces
associations la lune qui reste quand
même beaucoup d'interrogations sur sur
ce projet de loi
ça va dans le bon sens mais il ya des
encore des amplement y glisser on a
l'impression que le président de la
république il est en complet décalage
face à la situation on sait par exemple
que la france est frappée par la crise
sanitaire du duc o vie de 19 depuis
plusieurs mois maintenant à ce que
c'était important
est-ce que c'était urgent de mettre en
place de parler de ceux de cette loi sur
le séparatisme religieuse qui n'aurait
pas fallu attendre que la situation
s'améliore la situation sanitaire
s'améliore ce que c'était vraiment une
priorité une urgence
je vais prendre votre question dans dans
l'autre sens ce qu'ils auraient dû
attendre moi je pense pas je pense
qu'elle aurait dit on parlait bien avant
globalement ça fait le ça fait trois ans
que le sujet sur la table que le
président travaille sur ces questions ou
là
finalement c'est un projet de loi qui
aurait pu être mené beaucoup plus tôt
parce que c'est une question qui est
quand même majeurs on aurait dû régler
le problème peut-être plus tôt pour
commencer à avoir des résultats
le président l'a dit c'est une lutte est
une bataille qui va durer des années
moi je pense au contraire que finalement
ça collerait pu être présenté avant la
crise sanitaire on aurait pu travailler
plutôt aller plus vite et plus fort
c'était sur ces questions là alors avant
même d'être prononcé ce discours à a été
décrié par la gauche l'extrême gauche
qui les trouvent stigmatise envers les
musulmans par l'extrême droite la droite
qui qui trouvent que c'est le discours
qu emmanuel macron n'ira pas assez loin
dans la lutte contre le séparatisme
religieux vous en pensez-quoi maintenant
après à bientôt une heure des discours
d' emmanuel macron et emmanuel macron il
n'écoute compter une question assez
assez complexe c'est qu'il n'est pas
naturellement hâlé sûr c'est sur ces
sujets là mais face au réel il obligé
d'apporter des réponses faso aurait elle
des concitoyens
à l'actualité devant les locaux de
charlie hebdo il est obligé de fournir
une réponse forte ce que de toute façon
nous n'avons pas le choix et c'est des
personnes qui ont décidé de mener une
guerre contre la france contre la
république
c'est un projet de la république contre
l'islamisme radical contre un islam
politique et il faut apporter une
réponse et on voit la difficulté du
propos présidentiel parce que c'est un
thème et c'est un sujet sur lequel le
pré le président n'est pas naturellement
à l'aise il est obligé de rappeler le
passé colonial de la france pour
s'exprimer sur ces sujets là de faire
attention à ne pas stigmatiser mais les
musulmans et l'immense majorité des
musulmans qui exercent leur foi dans le
respect des règles de la république ne
se sentent pas stigmatiser lorsqu'on
parle de séparatisme lorsqu'on nomme le
problème c'est parfois même eux qui sont
les premières victimes de ce phénomène
là donc on sent que c'est un sujet qui
est pris avec des pincettes par le
présent de la république parce qu'il
n'est pas naturellement à l'aise avec ce
sujet là est vrai que glisser merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions merci
pour cette analyse je rappelle que vous
êtes le directeur de la communication du
think tank hall millénaire